uh if he if he has a push or you're
doing we're still working on
so when he has this push his push is
going that way
you see but through uh a particular
organization
he he can push and he's i'm aiming his
push down on my
on the ground you see so just to show
you
this will do from the grips okay so
if i am up here and he's going to push
me over
but there's so many joints and tissues
and fluids in my body
uh that i can reorganize myself in such
a way
go ahead that his energy is just pushing
me down
on the ground and he can push really
hard and he's just
uh making my back foot go deeper and
deeper into the mat
not making it pull ball over my back
foot
so this is why he's pushing he's pushing
if he let's go really fast
this is why i don't go flying forward
because i'm not doing this where if he
lets go
then i'm going to fall forward fall
forward it's also why as he goes to push
and he's just pushing that one single
path that i don't i don't need my front
leg
he can't push that over because there's
no energy going over that way it's just
going down the ground he's pushing
really hard
it's the same thing okay and so
they say the same thing happens on this
crazy chair of ours
okay so as he goes as he goes to push
whoa okay i have to be able
i feel that energy and i have to be able
to make it go
into into the ground i'm making it go
into the ground
same thing through the chair's legs and
then you then you can do your thing
but if i don't do that go and i push you
okay not good so we're going to do the
the same drill and he's pushing and i
have to be able
to uh aim it off the
chair legs never whoa
never aiming but back okay so he's doing
his thing
i'm feeling the the superior mass of the
earth
and again don't don't worry okay so
again
go ahead and do your energy i'm not
doing this you see how i'm starting to
come up
i'm not doing that i have to aim it
we're down he's pushing and we're just
down
he's going down the same way that was on
one leg i'm just aiming
in through the legs of the chairs that's
all i'm doing
okay
so often like uh
i go and i want to start to tilt him you
have
two active hands do you see you have two
young hats
or you just move out of the way
then you do like young hair
so as i'm going it's not that i'm moving
out of the way
i'm just falling i am moving
him in that adhesion
so it's not that he's pushing i get out
of the way and i get this little one to
two inch
thick okay this adhesion
is what's making him go so
it always poke you is easier to get
first because it's more consistent with
our uh our fear of threat cycle
meaning because i can displace him
but your cue is going to be much more
viable if it's not slippery
so you see otherwise you have to find
the exact
right angle or some sort of uh 90 degree
45 degree angle or or you can push into
it
but you don't you don't need that you
can you can have a focus
angle you can have one going sideways
going this way
as long as you have the friction so
i do want this even how no matter how
great my pokey projections are
but for kazushi you definitely
want to keep this stuck
i don't want my kazushi to be
uh an external deviation
and that's hard to do because it it'll
sometimes
look like i don't need to have a stuck
hand
i could just tilt him with external
deviation
so the the the the apparent
substitution uh is what's
the problem okay it's hard to uh
to have uh a apparent substitution
for coke you like everyone should
recognize that's not
it but it's harder to go like well i did
have you don't you don't really have it
you're all slippery over here okay
so as as you're doing it it's two
um adhesions just one is to
separate us and one is to adhere us
okay so it's not this is not slippery
and this is not getting out of the way
they're both moving
they're both adhering
both in here and bowls in here
okay both in here so
it's easy to overshoot it you see but i
i have to find that relationship
you see and then it's easy to ignore
that one do you see that
but i don't ignore it so i use both to
do that
you're going okay i'm gonna do that no
do this you see and then as you do
that as you're doing this hand uh using
this as an adhesion to pull
this is what we end up doing staples
dead but no
use the two hands to turn
same thing it's easy to go i'm gonna
take this one
no just turn this
okay so pay attention to what you're
doing
with the other hand once you think you
have his balance and you're going to
take it
pay attention to what you're doing with
this hand don't let it go
dead it is still pulling so
when i'm here like this yeah you see
okay there's my cool cue
but look you could have done it all on
that hand which means that hand could be
a redundant system
to to the kazushi
both hands have the same feeling
and then be cognizant that you're
slipping okay
there's still a friction in the midst of
cocaine